Fontus uses a solar panel and condenser attached
to a bike to convert water vapor from the
air into a bottle of drinking water.
And cellufoam is a wood-based, renewable,
biodegradable, shock-absorbing potential future
alternative to styrofoam.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
Cota wants to charge every device within 30
feet - wirelessly.
In development since 2001, the transmitter,
which is made up of thousands of tiny antennas
angled slightly different from one another,
receives RF pings from a microchip receiver
embedded on your devices and reflects them
back with an increased power level of up to
1 watt -- and the process is repeated 100
times per second.
The charge speed is one-fifth to one-third
of USB but it continuously charges untethered
until the battery is full whether it’s in
your hand, pocket, or on the table.
But the concept isn’t just for phones - it’s
for wireless door locks, smoke detectors,
remote controls, video game controllers, or
electric toothbrushes.
It’ll be another five years before this
becomes commercially available.
A new smart pill seeks to measure the gas
inside you.
The impact of gas on health is poorly understood,
in part because it's difficult to measure
inside the gut.
So the new gas pills detect hydrogen, methane
and carbon dioxide, and wirelessly transfer
the results to an app.
Researchers from RMIT in Melbourne believe
this could lead to a future of optimized diets
customized for all individuals.
In 1781, Benjamin Franklin actually proposed
the study of farts.
In an essay that was part science and part
humor, Franklin cited the same problems: that
internal gases were difficult to understand
and measure.
He hoped to find a drug that made farts smell
like perfume.
235 years later we may not have realized Franklin's
dream of lavender flatulence, but we're on
the path to understanding the effects of diet
on gut disorders like IBS and Crohn's disease.
FGF21 is a life-extending, immune function
boosting hormone in mice.
Researchers at the Yale School of Medicine
found that increasing the levels of the hormone
produced in the thymus gland led to a 40%
lifespan extension.
If, and this is a big if, that were to apply
to humans someday, it would raise the average
life expectancy from about 79 to over 110
years old.
They do believe the implications for improving
immune function in the elderly could help
combat illnesses such as type-2 diabetes and
cancer.
Addibots are mobile 3D printing robots that
could fill potholes.
It was first tested by repairing skating cuts
in ice by essentially printing ice - precisely
depositing water kept just above freezing.
For roads, the additive manufacturing robots
will need to keep tar materials at a high
temperature, so further research and development
is currently underway.
Spermbots.
To help combat male infertility, researchers
from Germany have developed magnetically-driven
microhelices that go over the tail of sperm
and act as motors.
They’ve successfully driven sperm in the
lab but are still far from beginning human
clinical trials for the cyborg sperm.
Michigan Engineering is developing a full-page
braille display for the visually impaired.
The pneumatic display uses bubbles driven
by air or fluid, which is much cheaper than
existing electronic displays that can cost
up to $55,000.
The challenge now is to fit all 5 to 10 thousand
physically controlled dots in a compact, mobile
space.
The GyroGlove aims to control tremors in the
hands of people with Parkinson’s disease.
A mechanical gyroscope on the back of the
hand resists the hand movement caused by tremors
by up to 90%.
They hope to launch in the U.K. by the end
of 2016 but first need to try to make it spin
silently and remain balanced.
VertiGO is a wall-climbing robot.
The collaboration between Disney Research
Zurich and ETH easily transitions from ground
to wall by maximizing thrust and minimizing
vehicle weight.
It features two propellers for thrust and
a carbon fibre baseplate to minimize weight.
Mostly I just want one.
Finally, here’s Boston Dynamics' Atlas robot
doing some household chores.
I’m gonna leave you with FlyAbility - a
drone with a spherical freely rotating protective
cage - and as always - thanks for watching.
Keeping in touch by means of the amazing new
“Bellboy” is the Bell System’s answer
today for doctors, salesmen, delivery men
or anyone who must be available at all times
in the fast paced world of Century 21.
When someone calls and you are out, you can
be reached by dialing your Bellboy code number.
When you get a signal on the Bellboy you can
go to a phone to call your office or home
to get the message.